cela va où devraient tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé pour l'union chrétienne
démocrate
ils ont enregistré les pires scores de
leur histoire dont deux états clé du sud
ouest de l'allemagne dans le bade
vinterberg est également en rhénanie
palatinat
suite à ce vote il risque sérieusement
de se retrouver exclue du gouvernement
dans ces deux régions au terme du
mercato des coalitions le cas échéant
cela pourrait se traduire par une
répétition au niveau national de ce qui
va arriver au niveau local si l'union
chrétienne démocrate est la grande
perdante
le grand gagnant est le parti vert dans
le bade vinterberg est également en
rhénanie palatinat où ils sont bien
placés pour faire partie du futur
gouvernement de coalition
selon les dirigeants du parti vers les
électeurs montrent qu'ils en ont plus
qu'assez du statut cours comme cela a
été mentionné
la cdo et son pendant en bavière l'union
chrétienne sociale la séance où sont
impliqués dans un large scandale de
corruption qui a déjà mené à la
démission de trois députés pour ce qu'on
a qualifié de profit de guerre autour de
la pandémie ninkovic 9
il aurait obtenu de l'argent contre des
contrats pour l'approvisionnement en eau
pays et masquer ce scandale qui s'ajoute
au mécontentement grandissant vis-à-vis
de la gestion de la pandémie a fait
chuter le bloc de l'union conservatrice
à 30 % dans les sondages nationaux les
taux le plus bas depuis un an
mais l'insatisfaction ne s'exprime pas
que dans les sondages ce week-end est l
anniversaire de la première
manifestation anti confinement
aujourd'hui encore des gens sont
descendus dans les rues d'allemagne pour
exprimer leur mécontentement vis-à-vis
de la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement de coalition
ces résultats au bas d'une tare berne
et en rhénanie-palatinat ne sont que le
début d'une très grosse année électorale
en allemagne dont l'apothéose sera la
grande élection du bundestag
en septembre nous serons alors qui
prendra la suite d'un gain la marque
elle